[Music]
so
i'm getting the sense that
balance isn't a thing
not in the way that we understand it
when i'm asked the question the question
is always asked this way how do you
balance it all balance is a verb how do
you balance it all
and we've got all the analogies walking
in tight ropes spinning plates juggling
balls some balls are plastic some are
glass which ones do you let drop i don't
know john all that sounds stressful
you just rattled off like nine crocheted
pillows
well that's that's these cliche answers
you get from people that we see as
successful and the truth is when i look
at jugglers they don't look real happy
or balanced or relaxing in their life i
don't want to do that it looks like it
looks stressful and hard and it also
looks like i could do all that and i've
done all that walk the tightrope spin
the plates juggle the balls
and still feel like something's not
right in my life and still feel like
i'm not balanced whatever that means and
so i started asking a different question
what if balance isn't something you do
how you balance it all
what if instead it's something you
feel what if it's something you create
what if you could be a balanced person
in an out of balance world what if you
could create a sense of balance and
still be busy
what if balance looks more like
peace
being confident in your choices when you
say yes to this thing or the no to that
thing what if it looks more like i don't
know just being happy
in your life and how you spend your time
and shaking the guilt that's been
following you around for a long time i
think when we ask
about balance that's what we really want
we just want to be proud of how we spend
our time in this one life we've been
given we want to shake this guilt that
just haunts us everywhere we go
and so that is the version of balance
i define in the book and
you stole my book title with your whole
redefining anxiety thing i wanted to be
redefining balance but we did we did
come up with something else
i don't think balance is about balancing
at all as we talk about it i think we
have this pressure
to have this 50 50 split between work at
home or we're more common to do
everything for an equal amount of time
i'm gonna work out and spend time with
my spouse and spend time at church and
spend time with my kids and spend time
at work and also personal goals and time
with god and
that sounds stressful um and it's not
realistic and so the the thesis of the
whole book is life balance isn't
doing everything for an equal amount of
time it's about doing the right things
at the right time and when you do that
you will actually feel that sense of
balance you've been looking for and
that's the kind of balance i walk them
through in this book that's awesome
so i had this this thing happened to me
the other day we i took my first
vacation in forever and we just went to
like a
koa me and my family and then we went
with another family with little kids
and we had like a pregame meeting where
the four of us like me and my wife and
and the other couple we all met and said
what are you what are you looking to get
out of uh how did you visualize this how
did how do you see this vacation
planning like well it was it was
basically i could be weird and awkward
and well my wife was trying to predict i
mean trying to prevent that so what do
you want to get out of this vacation
what do you want to
and
it hit me
in a way that it i've thought about this
before i've talked about but it never it
never hit me and tell me if this circles
back here if you see this
i think at first blush i wanted to go on
vacation so i could do nothing the goal
was this illusion of nothing okay
and i would go and i don't i didn't have
a picture of it i just wanted to not be
doing these other things
which was food prep and being around
people and talking and working with it
but i didn't have a thing of what we're
going to go do i just wanted to not be
doing those things which meant i just
want to do nothing
and then i've looked at
the idea like i can't wait to retire
i've had buddies that kept me on 20
years from retirement i think i don't i
don't want to just do nothing and i see
a trajectory towards
getting to
like my recliner at the end of every day
like people just can't they work all day
i can get here and then go to bed and
repeat
feels like this idea of balance i'm
going to run run run run run run run so
that i can get to this place where i
don't have to do anything yeah and i
realized that doing nothing
all the research tells me is that your
body falls apart your mind falls apart
your relationships fall apart then you
just die like if your goal is to do
nothing right yeah
but i don't know
that this idea of balance this feeling
of i'm either getting to a place where i
can finally do nothing
or i can do things that i want to do and
there will be no stress or pain or
frustration or any does it make sense
what are people looking for when they
say i want balance yeah yeah so that's
that's what's interesting because when i
walk through this whole
redefining what this could look like we
talk about what would it look like to be
have a sense of peace even in a world
that's chaotic or to be confident your
choices even when those choices are hard
but you make a good point i was actually
just talking to someone earlier today
about this i think sometimes we jump to
these conclusions about certain words
and we associate them with something
being really negative or wrong so for
example i'm tired so that must be
something's wrong or i'm stressed or i'm
overwhelmed or this is a really hard
season so i must be failing as if we
have this unspoken expectation that life
is supposed to be easy and effortless
and we know that it's not in our mind we
know intellectually it's not but then
when things get really hard
we think oh i'm failing this is terrible
and so on and the one of the things i
actually talk about this in the book but
i i want to i want to differentiate
between
just because you're tired doesn't mean
your whole world is out of balance just
because you're stressed doesn't mean
your whole world is out of balance just
because you're overwhelmed doesn't mean
your whole world is out of bounds each
of those things might be a clue if you
felt like that for a decade sure we
might need to figure out what's going on
with you but if you just didn't get
sleep last night you might just need a
nap or it might mean that you worked
really hard that day right you might
have a good thing yes you might have
just had a hard day or you're dealing
with a situation you don't know how to
deal with and so when we can separate
our
uh conclusions about our whole life from
these situations then i think it gives
us a greater sense of power and it
reduces all that guilt so so another
example i would use is um when i talk
about seasons
um i've been guilty of this where i look
around me
and i draw conclusions about myself
based on the season i'm in so as an
example my house is a mess so i'm a mess
and i'm failing as a mom i'm like no i
am not a mess i have three little kids
that make a mess every day multiple
times a day i am not a mess but if we're
not careful we'll do that we will draw
conclusions about ourselves from our
season and i just want people to know
your season is where you are not who you
are right your season is where you are
not who you are and so this is the
season you're in it's the season of
difficulty in your job or difficulty
with your health or difficulty with a
family member this isn't who you are